puissant c'est une vente aux enchères
peu banale qui a lieu à j non seulement
elle se déroule sur trois jours
mais elle fait suite à une longue
polémique opposant la commune de saint
brisson sur loire dans le loiret aux
amis du château
car les quelques 800 objets proposés
font partie du patrimoine historique de
ce château du 12e siècle légué à la
commune en juillet 87
nous avons donc le droit d'ouvrir tous
les placards et de vider tous les
placards et donc il y à une multitude de
vaisselle on a trouvé 30 de carafes et
c'est pour cela j'en profite pour dire
ses 32 40 mais je tiens absolument à les
vendre à l'unité
non pas pour faire un chiffre fort mais
pour que chacun puisse avoir un souvenir
du château parmi les belles pièces
proposées à la vente ce lustre pamiers à
9 branches si les dorer mise à prix 4500
euros ou encore cette coupe frappé aux
armes du marquis de saint brisson les
marquis de saint brisson a commandé la
faïencerie devient cette coupe dont qui
est sûre veut ce pied de bronze cette
coupe
elle a été exécutée les collectionneurs
vont être ravis par maroua quand un
célèbre faïenciers et les armes des
marques y sont sur le tour de la coupe
donc c'est un objet exceptionnel parmi
les acheteurs plusieurs membres de
l'association des amis du château qui
ont tenté d'empêcher cette vente et qui
par défaut ont acquis une demi douzaine
d'objets symboliques les objets qui on
vient d'acheter en fait c'est en vue de
constituer un fonds de
deux collections concernant les
des objets qui sont intrinsèques au
château de saint brisson enfin qui ont
une connotation purement historique et
pour lequel on les exposera probablement
lors de journées du patrimoine
lors d'expositions temporaires ou
éventuellement n'en fera don à un musée
ou une autre association qui a un
caractère purement historique il ne
restera au château de saint brisson que
les meubles et quelques objets présentés
par la commune reste à savoir ce qu'on
fera le nouveau propriétaire